[Applause]
you know you really are starting to feel
it now you walk outside and you're
starting to feel that intense
uh holiday spirit here in new york of
course last night was the annual tree
lighting ceremony in rockford center
anybody here have you seen the tree
today
it's right out there somewhere um if you
look hard enough you'll see it
no uh it's uh it's it's beautiful the
tree lighting ceremony
i i just heard this this morning over
100 000 people
showed up uh to watch that ceremony and
commit crimes in midtown
and uh no 100 000 people and uh you know
that's exciting
a lot of people talk about the christmas
tree lighting isn't that great
sure it's fine but we here at late night
also have an annual tradition to ring in
the holidays right and i think our
tradition
is pretty special too and i want to talk
about it right now ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the annual late night with
conan o'brien
christmas lighting spectacular
from studio 6a and rockefeller center
it's the late night with conan o'brien
christmas lighting spectacular
join us as we usher in the holiday
season
with a musical celebration featuring
stars
too big to name plus special guests
too big today and now please welcome
your host conan
o'brien
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you everyone hello and
welcome to the late night christmas
lighting spectacular we've got a great
show for you tonight now let me
introduce my co-host for this evening
celebrating her 10th year on access
hollywood the lovely
ms nancy o'dell
thank you very much i have to think that
new york is such a
magical place to spend the holiday it
sure is nancy
and tonight we're gonna kick off the
holiday season with the lighting of this
glorious six
foot tall north american vogota
that's right ladies and gentlemen it
wouldn't be christmas without a pagoda
no
it sure would not no lighting the vigoda
is an american tradition that dates back
centuries
now over the years and today more than
ever the pagoda has become a symbol of
hope and joy
in new york for the holidays and connie
did you know that pagodas typically have
lifespans of 200 years wow
i didn't know that but nancy if there's
one question that everybody asks
it's how did you get such a big vigoda
into your studio
well this year six foot tall north
american avagoda
came from poughkeepsie new york
specifically the front yard of joan and
barry wendell
now he was here when we bought the house
right you realize how long ago that was
that over 50 years absolutely
he was small he was small he's grown
the whole world is going to be watching
our age
on television yeah yeah it's going to be
great it's going to be great but
i'd still know i'm still going to miss
him
removing the vegota was no easy task
first the vegota was wrapped and bound
to prevent
limb breakage then he was carefully
pried from the ground
hoisted up and placed on a flatbed truck
all right
let's go to the 30 mile journey to
rockefeller center
and studio 6a
[Music]
oh truly amazing oh
yes now we'll be lighting the christmas
pagoda in just a few minutes
but first what would a new york holiday
spectacular be
without an ice rink we've got one right
here in studio 6a
thanks to our limited space we're proud
to bring you the world's smallest ice
rink
and conan you know what this is a very
interesting factoid
there is enough ice in this ring to fill
a rink
twice its size half as deep
incredible and who better to use the
world's smallest ice rink than world
champion bronze medalist
galit chait and sergey saknovski
and now the legion sergey perform an
interpretive skating routine to the tune
of have a merry little christmas
performed by grammy eligible recording
artist
david cassidy
[Music]
yourself a merry
little christmas
[Music]
now
oh wow thank you oh yeah thank you david
that was wonderful now david you're from
new jersey uh did your parents take you
to see the pagoda when you were a kid
oh yeah of course but i i have never
been so very
close to the viking it's incredible now
david isn't it true you only agreed to
appear on our spectacular if we'd plug
your new broadway musical
the rat pack is back opening december
12th at the supper club
that's right the rat pack is back is
opening on december 12th at the supper
club and
still just nothing but a promotional
[ __ ]
so you're not on access hollywood
weeknights at 7
30 that would be monday through friday
with our weekend edition airing on the
weekends
no i'm not thanks a lot david
nancy conan thank you very much
did you know that the very first pagoda
was brought to new york in 1802 by
benjamin franklin
and that tonight's pagoda is over 1 000
months old oh wow and this north
american pagoda looks like it's ready to
shine
now that shouldn't be a problem because
this year's pagoda has been wrapped in
over 120
watt bulbs that is three watts for every
square inch of pagoda
now folks while we wait for the big
moment here's a very special performance
of hark the herald angel
singh by new york's own under-rehearsed
reluctant
children's choir
thank you very much kids the under
[Applause]
did you know that tonight's pagoda
thrives in warm climates and
that i actually walked in on my
brother's kissing once
none of us knew that i remember and you
folks should remember that tonight's
show is being simulcast on the world
famous
astrovision screen in new york's times
square
now of course using the astrovision
screen is very very expensive technology
so we should use it very wisely and not
waste any time
hey everyone check this out
[Applause]
wow that was incredible it sure was
definitely now
here's a fun holiday fact for you there
is enough glass
in that astrovision screen to make over
4 000 crack pipes
wow okay and now with a holiday greeting
for our latino audience
with their rendition of felice navidad
please welcome once again
the under-rehearsed reluctant children's
[Applause]
choir
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks so much kids thank you very much
that was amazing
thank you guys that was very amazing oh
yeah yeah
none of them want to be here the
under-rehearsed reluctant children's
choir
weren't they wonderful they were
wonderful very under-rehearsed yes they
were
under-enthusiastic of course yes all
right well here's an interesting tidbit
about children that you may not have
known
it is legal to adopt them but you are
not allowed to sell them
i learned that last year wow yeah it's
good for us all to remember thank you
wait a minute nancy i think i hear
something
yeah those bells should only mean one
thing
a visit from triumph the insult comic
dog everybody
oh yes on beaches
here we go i saw mommy
humping santa claus thank you very much
it was so traumatic don't you see
sing along if you know it folks she
haunt his filthy leg
then he made her sit and beg
then i was forced to watch as he put
eggnog on his crotch oh and i
saw mommy humping santa's filthy leg
it's the source of all my hostility
if only santa had licked himself or
gotten some from an elf i think 99
[Applause]
get in on this
[Applause]
incredible thank you triumph well the
moment we've all been waiting for is
finally here it's time to light the
vagoda
are you all ready let's do it ten
nine eight seven six
five four three two
[Applause]
[Music]
one
billy jones